Oliver Stone he's made good movies he
has made terrible movies now he brings
us savages savages right so savages is
the story of a trio these two guys ones
it's like really granola hippie botanist
type and the other is this soldier type
who's like alright I'm gonna kick the
[ __ ] out of everything if that doesn't
work I'm going to shoot everything type
and they're both dating Blake Lively and
it's not like both dating is in she's
dating him and she's dating him but they
don't know about it I was like straight
up Utah type [ __ ] where they all know
about it they're all cool with it that's
when you know you found a friend indeed
and these two guys have a specialty and
a business in which they grow the best
cannabis like ever made and Salma
Hayek's this Mexican cartel type she
sees what they do she wants to become
business partners with them they say no
and so she kidnaps Blake Lively and they
get pissed so they're gonna get her back
by any means necessary now we have
savages our movie right so how was
savages it was actually pretty cool
I actually liked most of the
performances in this movie the one that
I'm on the fence about is that one dude
from John Carter I'm pretty sure he did
the Sam Worthington thing where he was
like all right I filmed the movie now we
need to lock down three more movies
before that one movie gets released that
is how he has come out with three movies
this year funny thing is he worked for
this movie I'm not gonna say he doesn't
bother me yet cuz he's kind of like
Kristen Stewart and the Snow White and
the Huntsman movie it's like yeah she
worked for that movie but I'm not gonna
say yeah she's a good actress I haven't
seen that one movie that people say
she's good in so I'm still on the fence
sin goes with this John Carter guy in
this movie the granola kid guy you know
like the pacifist hippy type he was
actually really cool I liked him funny
thing is someone like that really
shouldn't be in this line of work
because crime and death is going to
happen it's actually one of the elements
of the movie that I really liked is the
fact it's like you need to get over
yourself we need to shoot things in
people it's the only way we're gonna
possibly get her back so he has to deal
with that fact it was actually really
cool to see now when the movie started
out it was all like backstories Blake
Lively doing voiceover and she's like oh
this is how this person met this person
this is how this became this is how that
became that and you're like I'm really
IIIi don't like Blake Lively doing
voice-overs officially I don't like it
so can we please move past this and get
to the movie because that's what I would
like
so finally you know the movie picks up
and you don't hear her voice overs and
she doesn't bother you that much I
really liked her in the movie the town
but she I'm just saying a little bit of
Blake Lively goes a long way she's great
to look at voiceovers you're not looking
at her you're just hearing her voice
it's like all of the negative none of
the strings I'm saying she looks really
attractive it's actually a compliment
another one I like those movies Benicio
del Toro you know me I've given del Toro
a hard time a few times he was really
good in this movie he was this hardcore
Mexican hitman type or like that guy is
just soulless but easy el del Toro plays
one of the sickest bastards I've seen in
a movie in a while and he was really
good at it but it's an Oliver Stone
movie so when people get stressed out
they really get stressed out it's
actually it take him to the verge of
being funny but they're not cartoons
Anil del Toro did that really well in
this movie another one who did it well
was John Travolta he plays the DEA agent
who knows what these two guys do and so
he doesn't turn him in and he actually
throws him a bone here and there and his
John Travolta isms come out when he gets
stressed out too and you chuckle a bit
you laugh he was really good in the
movie he stole the scenes he was in
Benicio del Toro stole the scenes that
he was in some of the elements are
predictable and sloppy you see this
foreshadowing happening it's really like
if you don't see it coming I have to
assume you zoned out for that Saints the
only way you won't see the foreshadowing
in these scenes the movie is really
violent - it's like Oliver Stone going
ok we get it you haven't liked a few of
my other movies here I'm not saying
violence makes for good movies I'm
saying this movie being violent made it
a better movie and because most of us
out there are not the kind of person who
you know bangs a chick who's also
banging your friends we don't have these
weird open love triangle situations
happening in our lives we don't really
identify with these people you're like
okay they took your [ __ ] chick ID you
can get another one but you know in the
end it's like total love to them and I
get that however that's not what I
thought about that's not why I cared
it's when they started kicking asses I
really cared however the movies going
really good and then the ending happens
you're like I almost want to call this
movie Mass Effect 3 because it was good
until the end
there's no DLC for movies though it just
is what it is it happened either it's a
really cheap move and it's a cop-out and
it irritates you or it's just silly and
it's a cheap
and and it irritates you in the end -
the end it's a really fun movie and a
really cool movie savages is a strong
good time no alcohol required I wanted
to get it to blu-ray but didn't quite
get there so what is your favorite
Oliver Stone moving is there one of the
past decade whatever it is comment below
let me know
um as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]